[Music]
in october 2000 the president of iraq
saddam hussein announced they would no
longer be selling oil in u.s dollars
only in euros
[Music]
which on the surface is an innocent
change what's the big deal
the big deal is that iraq has the fifth
largest petroleum reserves in the world
and in the 2000s it had become the
world's fifth largest oil producer so
when hussein decided to start selling
oil in euros instead of dollars the us
wasn't too happy by february 2003 he has
sold over 3 billion barrels of oil for
26 billion euros
a month later the us invaded iraq my
fellow citizens
at this hour
american and coalition forces are in the
early stages of military operations
to disarm iraq
to free its people
and to defend the world from grave
danger in an operation ironically called
operation iraqi freedom
they overthrew saddam and by june just
four months later the country was back
to selling oil in dollars
years later a number of us officials
started to let the truth seep out former
head of u.s operations in iraq general
john abazade said of course it's about
oil we can't really deny that
former fed chairman alan greenspan wrote
in his memoir that quote i'm saddened
that it's politically inconvenient to
acknowledge what everyone knows the iraq
war is largely about oil end quote
and former defense secretary chuck hagel
said the same in 2007 quote people say
we're not fighting for oil of course we
are end quote
venezuela 2002
[Music]
coincidentally venezuela also has large
oil reserves in fact they have the
largest proven oil reserves in the world
at the time hugo chavez was in charge of
venezuela as the dictator president
but chavez a die-hard anti-american
leader was about to make the same grave
mistake that saddam hussein made he
planned to start selling oil for euros
instead of the mighty american dollar
well we can't have that now can we so in
2002 the u.s backed a coup against
chavez which ultimately failed but it
crippled the country and its economy
empires are built on oil yet despite
having the largest oil reserves in the
world today venezuela is one of the
poorest economies in the world
do other factors play into that many
we've talked about a few of them on this
channel before but going against the us
is probably a big no-no
libya 2009
eerily similar to venezuela and iraq
libya has the largest oil reserves in
africa and they weren't doing that bad
they did a great job managing all those
oil revenues building up a 143 ton gold
reserve according to wikileaks they had
the highest gdp per capita in africa and
libya was on track to become the most
influential country in africa
and also similar to venezuela and iraq
muammar gaddafi the leader of libya
suggested all muslim and african
countries buy oil from libya using a new
currency backed by their giant gold
reserves instead of us dollars
in other words they wanted to sell oil
in exchange for gold instead of us
dollars and other major african
governments were ready to support
but i think we can all guess what
happened next
nato led a military coalition into libya
in the name of freedom of course and on
august 20th 2011 muammar gaddafi was
executed by libyan militias backed by
u.s drone strikes years later it was
discovered in hillary clinton's emails
that nato really wanted to overthrow
gaddafi's government mainly because of
this plan for an african gold-backed
currency supported by libya's oil
reserves this was libya before
and this is libya today
a failed state with widespread poverty
and an ongoing civil war why because
each of these countries tried to break
away from using the dollar as payment
for their oil and each of them faced the
consequences of america's wrath
out of all them none were able to
recover from america's interventions in
the name of freedom and in taking down
an axis of evil and their terrorist
allies constitute an axis of evil
servants of evil the cult of evil a
monumental struggle
of good versus evil and they usually
ended up far worse than they were before
all these countries had problems but all
of these countries had huge economic
potential despite their dictator leaders
but as soon as they moved away from
selling oil in dollars the u.s swooped
in and quickly put an end to the party
[Music]
and they're not alone which begs the
question why is it so important for oil
to be only sold in u.s dollars what's
the big deal why is america so quick to
liberate people as soon as this oil for
dollars arrangement is threatened
this is the petrodollar how your money
is inexorably linked to oil and water
[Music]
like we've mentioned before even though
there's still a lot of bad that happens
in the world the great news is that even
if you live in an area that doesn't have
much opportunity with the internet as
long as you're willing to learn the
right in-demand skills you can make a
first world wage in the third world
country and thus transform your life
that's where skillshare comes in today's
sponsor skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes that you can use to build
profitable skills that allow you to
freelance that allows you to land a
remote job for a very reasonable price
like this class on the fundamentals of
ux design or user experience ux
designers have an average pay of a
hundred and five thousand dollars and
with skillshare you can start learning
the basics of it right now it's taught
by marik mccloskey who's the director of
research over at user testing and it has
over 24 000 students or this class on
animating with ease in adobe after
effects where you can learn how to make
professional animations this one is
taught by jake marletts a motion
designer and it has over 22 000 students
and skillshare is always launching new
premium classes just like these so
you'll definitely find a ton of classes
that speak to you and if you like videos
like this you should consider supporting
yourself and skillshare because they
really do make this channel possible the
first 1 000 of my subscribers to click
the link in the description will get a
one month free trial of skillshare so
you can start exploring your creativity
today pause the video and click the link
in the description below to join now
the british pound had dominated the
global economy since the early 19th
century but especially after the first
world war it began to lose steam so by
the start of the second world war the
dollar unquestionably took the throne
from the british pound as the most
influential currency by the end of world
war ii the allies including america and
the uk pretty much knew they were going
to win the war and being that so much of
the world had been decimated it was one
of those rare moments in history where
it was time to rewrite the rules of the
game to reset the deck and set up a new
game for how the world economy will
recover from world war ii
so in the last few months of world war
ii leaders from 44 countries met at a
hotel in red and west new hampshire to
decide how the new global economy would
run and what its financial bedrock would
be at the time the world was still on
the gold standard where every paper
money was backed by actual gold in a
vault somewhere
but us and uk policymakers had a much
more modern flexible system in mind and
being that the us had the most wealth
was a war torn like europe and by far
the most gold in the world after many
european nations stashed their gold
there for safe keeping it had the most
negotiating power at bretton woods and
was able to seize control economist john
mayer keem's pushed for a global
currency called the bond corps that many
countries would manage but the us wanted
more control so instead of a new
international currency the brandon woods
conference settled on the us dollar as
the de facto global currency where the
dollar would be at the center of all
trade and international settlement and
it would be packed to go at 35 an ounce
this would be the start of the bretton
woods system that would put the us at
the center of the world's economy
trusted by the world to hold enough gold
to keep the system afloat this meant
that the paper money printed by one
single nation was used everywhere it
became the main currency held in central
banks the main currency used in
international transactions international
investments and all aspects of the
global economy
all based on the trust that there would
be enough gold to pay up if needed
and over the next few decades the us
kept that promise the american economy
exploded the us became the largest
creditor in the world and the bretton
woods system seemed to be working
wonders
but the only problem was this entire
system hinged on the fact that the us
was on the gold standard meaning that
the nation issuing the currency the
entire world used wasn't able to print
more money on the man at their will to
fund let's say wars or giant social
programs because if the u.s were able to
print more money whenever they wanted
more wars or social programs they would
benefit at the expense of devaluing the
money the entire world used
so if they could print all the money
they could the entire world would be at
their whim but luckily that's not how
the system worked we were on the gold
standard the us couldn't inflate
everyone's dollars at their whim but
then it all changed
1963 president john f kennedy was
assassinated in dallas and soon after
the u.s chose a radically different
economic path filled with you guessed it
expensive social programs and expensive
wars president johnson's great society
social programs along with cold war
spending and the invasion of vietnam
caused u.s debt to skyrocket see unlike
world war ii of the korean war the
vietnam war was the first american war
waged almost entirely on debt it was a
period of guns and butter guns as in
wars butter as in social programs the
one nation the world trusted to uphold
the entire financial system was drowning
in debt just 11 billion in gold back 24
billion in u.s dollars and other nations
were starting to get nervous the french
and the british soon came knocking were
friends even sending a warship to new
york demanding their gold back backed
into a corner the u.s thought well i
need more money to fund more wars and
social programs i can't print more money
because of the rules of the bretton
woods system we all agreed on and
countries i'm holding gold for are
knocking even though i'm drowning in
debt i still am at the center of the
world i still have the most influence
and power on paper the world is supposed
to hold me accountable but in reality
whatever i do the world has to follow
whether they like it or not so instead
of following the world set45 bretton
woods why not just rewrite them one more
time so a few days after france sends
the battleship to new york demanding
their gold back nixon shocked the world
with this message
we must protect the position of the
american dollar as a pillar of monetary
stability around the world accordingly
i have directed the secretary of the
treasury to take the action necessary to
defend the dollar against the
speculators i have directed secretary
connelly to suspend temporarily the
convertibility of the dollar into gold
or other reserve assets i have directed
secretary connelly to suspend
temporarily the convertibility of the
dollar into gold or other reserve assets
except in amounts and conditions
determined to be in the interest of
monetary stability and in the best
interest of the united states
actually the french sent like a
battleship to new york city
in august of 71 to like redeem their
gold and the british asked for like
about three billion pounds of gold nixon
in a famous speech uh actually went on
tv and he he declared this was a few
days after uh we're ending the gold
window you know other nations can no
longer redeem their dollars for gold as
the us was was was entering into like a
very inflationary decade basically in
1971 nixon changed the very foundation
of the entire global financial system in
a total of 16 seconds by giving the
middle finger to countries wanting their
gold back as a temporary measure but as
we should all be well acquainted with by
now few things are as permanent as
temporary measures
this will mark the end of the bretton
woods system the world went into a
financial crisis the nixon shock had
devastating effects on foreign economies
and america's response to this crisis
well in the words of nixon himself i
don't give a [ __ ] about the lira for the
first time in modern history the world
transitioned from the gold standard to a
global reserve currency not backed by
anything at all just the blind faith
that the us dollar was worth something
fiat money and this all happened at the
snap of the us's finger the us came out
on top once more but then just a few
years later another essential crisis hit
the u.s
oil so first of all you have this change
between like colonial powers kind of
controlling oil to sovereign
dictatorships controlling oil
1973 the u.s was supporting israel in
the yom kippur war also known as the
fourth arab israeli war so as a
collective middle finger to the us opec
the cartel of arabic petroleum exporters
announced an embargo on oil sales to the
us and the quadrupling of global oil
prices the arabs made an economic power
play as punishment for this country's
support of israel 11 arab countries cut
off all oil shipments to the united
states we are heading toward the most
acute shortages of energy since world
war ii why was it so devastating because
even in the 70s oil dominated every
aspect of america's daily lives it
fueled our cars it was needed to produce
plastic it provided electricity for our
homes and factories it was even in the
fertilizer needed to grow food so if you
cut off america's oil supply cargo ships
stop delivery trucks stop people can't
drive to work you can literally collapse
the american empire simply by taking
away its oil and that's what opec was
threatening and through this oil crisis
these arab nations got filthy rich so
you had oil kind of going from like two
dollars a barrel where it was for like a
long time to 10 11 12 a barrel now this
created
an enormous
flow of cash for the saudis and and the
opec nations this was a historic moment
because it was so much money um you know
essentially uh the
opec ran a surplus and the rest of the
world ran a net deficit i mean i can't
stress how much just how much money came
into the coffers of these arab regimes
and by the end of that year 73 the
dollar had actually lost 20 percent of
its value against other top currencies
and people called this like a peacetime
redistribution of global wealth on a
scale that had never been seen in living
memories that's why when opec exposes
giant weakness in america by restricting
their oil supply the u.s had to make
sure something like this would never
happen again they have to make sure that
somehow the us dollar still came out on
top so they could keep all this giant
spending going on wars and social
programs the oil regimes have more money
than they knew what to do with and the
u.s needed a way to fund its spending
enter the petrol dollar
in 1974 the u.s sent william simon the
new treasury secretary to strike a deal
with saudi arabia his main objective was
to get the kingdom to sell oil in only
u.s dollars in exchange america will
provide the kingdom with military aid
protection and equipment in short saudi
would have a ton of dollars lying around
because everyone who wanted oil from
them would have to pay for it in dollars
they could then buy u.s treasuries with
those dollars and finance america's
spending that way they would at least
get a return on those dollars along with
protection from the us instead of
letting that money just sit there and
since the world ran on oil making oil
buyable only in dollars was a great way
to make sure everyone kept using the
dollar thus making it remain the reserve
currency of the world and the best part
yet whenever america needs more oil to
fuel for the american empire they could
just print more money because oil was
only sold in dollars and the us
controlled the money printer for this
fiat currency that was no longer pegged
to gold and this really helped us of
course in the soviet uh struggle with
the soviets because through this system
we could print
you know we could print money to buy oil
um soviets had to literally dig it out
of the ground or somehow get dollars in
another way and this gave us a huge huge
advantage but essentially uh you know
simon and kissinger said hey and this is
a quote from simon you know if the opec
nations put a larger amount of their
accumulated funds into investment in
this country this was a way of saving
the day because the the other way to
save the day would be if the american
public spent less and saved more and
that was not going to happen with nixon
you know facing impeachment so the idea
is they were like we need to get other
nations to finance our debt because like
we're not going to do it through raising
taxes there's no way so you know
essentially the deal was in the
petrodollar system uh that these dollars
that these opec nations were earning
that they would they would not only like
force the sale of oil to be in dollars
so all oil sales were like now
denominated in dollars but they would
take the earnings and they would
actually buy us debt with with the
profits and this is what we call
petrodollar recycling and and this
mechanism really saved uh dollar
hegemony i i think you know would be my
thesis both sides won in this
arrangement so in june 1974 kissinger
and crown prince fought signed the
agreements and thus the us dollar was
inextricably married to oil and the
petrol dollar was born it was a match
made in hell that outlasted almost every
american partnership that came after it
it wasn't necessarily like a market
decision would be the other thing i
would just like try to kind of hammer
home like these this was all ironed out
through like secret deals like you know
the saudis could have just kind of
pursued a broader portfolio of
investment they didn't have to go so
heavy on u.s debt they didn't have to
price oil in dollars these were
decisions they made in exchange for
protection okay in exchange for massive
amounts of weapons mass amounts of
protection so essentially the saudis
became you know non-market investors in
u.s debt and the u.s became
a non-market seller of weapons to the
saudis with saudi arabia holding a lot
of influence in the middle east it
didn't take long for other opec nations
to follow their lead if you want to buy
oil from them you'd have to do it in
dollars and by 1975 just one year later
saudi imports of u.s military equipment
stood at more than 5 billion
since everyone had to exchange their
currencies for dollars to buy oil demand
for dollars skyrocketed and so did the
value of the dollar and the stronger the
dollar compared to other currencies the
cheaper it got to import goods the
cheaper it was to invest abroad and the
cheaper it was to start businesses
outside the us to take over emerging
economies and to extend the us's
influence even further or in other words
the us dollar and the u.s empire
continued to reign supreme
and it built an almost unbreakable
alliance between the u.s and saudi
arabia that still last two today it also
meant that every time a nation
threatened the rule of the petrol dollar
the us would go to the ends of the earth
defending it under the guise of freedom
and liberation of course
[Music]
august 1990 iraq invades kuwait and
takes control of the country's oil
fields the iraqi military occupies the
country for seven months and since
kuwait was a major oil supplier to the
us surprise surprise they quickly got
involved liberated kuwait from the
oppression of iraq and got oil
production moving again as soon as
possible this would be known as the
first gulf war during the retreat iraqi
troops set fire to 600 kuwaiti oil wells
leading to some horrifying and
spectacular footage
[Music]
and then you have all the other examples
we went over at the beginning of this
video was saddam hussein announcing in
2000 that he would no longer sell oil in
dollars only euros which led to
operation iraqi freedom in 2003 with
hugo chavez announcing the same thing in
2002 they'll only sell oil in euros
instead of dollars which led to a u.s
backed coup with gaddafi of libya in
2009 trying to sell oil in gold leading
to his u.s backed execution and many
other examples we don't have time to
cover in all these cases the us claimed
that they were going after brutal
unethical dictators in order to free the
people operation iraqi freedom but the
u.s doesn't really care about dictators
only the ones that threaten u.s
supremacy in fact working and partnering
with dictatorships is a norm in u.s
geopolitical history as long as it
benefits america and the best example of
this is saudi arabia the country is
accused of horrific human rights
violations pretty much non-existent
women's rights and the murder of
journalists but you'll never hear a bush
or obama or trump or biden say a single
bad thing about saudi arabia although it
seems like the petrol dollar is
all-powerful that may not be the case
forever
[Music]
in just the last 100 years alone the
global economy has gone through a
whirlwind from the bretton woods system
at the end of world war ii to the end of
the gold standard and the start of the
fiat age with nixon in 1971 and the
birth of the petrol dollar in 1974 so
there's no reason to assume that this
petrol dollar system or the system of
relying on the us dollar is going to
last and in fact the power and reign of
the petrodollar and thus the us being
the dominant superpower is slowly waning
part of the reason is because of
renewable energy why do you think so
many countries are pushing for its
adoption it can't be entirely because
it's better for the environment maybe
it's partially because detaching
yourself from the dollar also detaches
you from the control of the us
another reason is because of the rise of
other empires like china the eu and
russia the us isn't the only one calling
the shots anymore sure oil may not
disappear for the next few decades but
as the sun sets on the golden age of
fossil fuels like crude oil the prospect
of the petrol dollar falling out of
favor becomes more and more real what
will replace it is anyone's best guess
the blaze 60 feet high like a huge
inexhaustible jet engine some of these
men earn a thousand dollars a day
[Music]
pictures from the first gulf war more
than 700 kuwaiti oil wells were set
ablaze by saddam
[Music]
the country engulfed by fire and choking
black smoke
and everywhere
the pitiless carnage of war
[Music]
if you are new here all i ask is that
you subscribe because we make video
essays just like this one every single
week on the most provocative stuff in
the world of business just like this
video and of course you can always
dislike unsubscribe and leave me your
best hate comments in the comments below
so you have nothing to lose if you want
more behind the scenes stuff then a lot
of kind of stuff you can follow me on
instagram at jtrend.io and if you want
to support the channel financially you
can check out some great classes on
skillshare with the link below that's
going to wrap it up for this video thank
you so much for watching you've been
awesome i've been jake stay dangerous
out there and i will see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
you